put put the brian stelter thing went on
cnn kai can you put that up real quick
i mean you have to realize here's an
author
who goes on cnn to sell his books
who's not necessarily a trump guy at all
this is not a he hates trump
and he the channel that he's supposed to
defend go to the last two minutes go
from uh
no go from go back go back 40 seconds go
from 240 go from 240.
play this i think it's important to
mention also you know as long as i've
known you
you never wanted to be political you
never wanted to know i didn't want to
touch this but
but to me freedom is that important
i told you this last time when we were
talking when we're over here i said
people are going to show up from the
word works
because i believe if your message is the
right message i believe the right people
will show up
listen when we started our company
insurance company we had 66 agents i'm
not
i've never once sold insurance to any of
my following and i've never once pitched
my company to anybody i don't do it
you've never
have i ever tried to sell you an
insurance policy no have i ever tried to
sell you an insurance bill i don't know
if you have a license
yeah i've never i've never even done
that to people around me right but i'm
gonna tell you what happened
a couple times certain events happen
that i can't take credit for
there's certain things that happen i'm
like there's no way in the world i get
credit for this no way in the world i
get credit for this
and you have uh uh eventually certain
things started happening i'm like listen
either the power out there whether it's
god energy whatever you want
either somebody wants this to become a
reality or they don't i'm not gonna
fight it if you don't want it to become
a reality
i'm just going to put my effort the
message that we have
is getting millions of eyeballs if
people want it they're going to show up
what's crazy is some of the people that
have showed you dms where i showed you
these are
well-known celebrities that can't
publicly talk about it well-known
athletes that cannot publicly talk about
it
but they listen to our podcast and they
agree with what we're talking about yeah
and they're saying it's so necessary
today what is the tipping point
a year two years five years ten years i
don't know but we're going to do our
part so
kai pull up this video real quick for us
to see here's a guy
michael wolff that's selling his book
landslide the final days of the trump
presidency
does that sound like a title that says
good things about trump by the way all
right
now watch how he torches cnn
go ahead is that how it works that's how
you got it
but yeah but i don't yeah but i don't
want you to think that
that that what i said at that point was
in any way inauthentic
i think the media has done a terrible
job on this i think
you yourself um you know why you're a
nice guy you know you're full of
sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem
of the media you know you come on here
and you and you have a
um you know a monopoly on truth
you know you know exactly how things are
supposed to be done
um you know you are why one of the
reasons
people can't understand the meaning side
turns against you
so what should i do differently michael
ask listen you know don't talk so much
listen more
you know people have genuine problems
with with
with the media the media doesn't get the
story right
the media exists in its own bubble
um that's true i agree you uh
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that
that that i just had to listen to people
saying the same old stuff
also you're incredibly repetitive it's
week after week i mean
you're the flip side of of of donald
trump
um you know fake news and you say
virtuous news
you know i they're they're not they just
figure out what is real i mean
well figuring out yeah figuring out what
is real is not so
is not so uh it's not so easy and and
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter to tell us what's
real
i'm sorry well then why'd you bother
coming on cnn four times this week watch
his answer
very honest you know
i i'm uh i'm i'm a book salesman
capitalism obviously right i'm grateful
you came on watch this i'll see you four
years and
i guess let's do it again in four years
thanks so much
see ya you know that was an intellectual
mismatch right there
he had you could just see the wheel
spinning he's never they're never
challenged
they don't even know what to do when
someone doesn't it's not an echo chamber
for them
so i freaked out bezos is adam and eve
rocket we talked about pam anderson
brandy love
we i we we looked at megan fox looking
better than she's ever looked in her
life and that right there was the
sexiest thing i've
seen all day are you kidding me and you
know what that is that here's what that
is
there is nothing like your own kid
coming to you telling you you're wrong
nothing it's very painful and you know
they're right there's nothing like
somebody from your own side coming to
and telling you you're wrong and that's
exactly what they're experiencing right
now
and he's going to sell a heck of a lot
more books because i think people from
either side are going to want to like
hear more from this guy you know it's
how much longer can they
keep it up man the media you know pat we
talked about it yesterday man like what
kills me about
this moment is like we are quantifiably
the most successful
humans to ever live true they're we are
the most literal we are the most
educated
we have the most access to nutrients we
are living longer we are living better
the average person today the middle
class person today lives a life
in excess of 18th century uh
oligarchs like we have access to like
climate control
you're never in a room that's too hot
you're never in a room that's too cold
you never have a belly that that's empty
you know you know
like and yet all we hear every single
day and this is an american thing i'm
not talking about across the world all
we hear
is how bad everything is yeah and
because things aren't perfect this the
marxists are selling our kids
specifically
that things aren't perfect so blow it up
you guys grew up in a world not even 30
years ago i was a kid there was
actual apartheid they want to tell us
that things are worse than they've ever
been there was apartheid in the 80s man
ireland and and ireland and britain were
blowing each other up
in the mid 90s clinton is the one who
who did the uh
the belfast agreement like that you
would literally have terrorist attacks
on the reg
and i'm not i'm not talking about you
know like we talk about in in war
ravaged
you know middle eastern countries that
have basically been a proxy for wars
between
united states and china united states
and russia we're talking about
britain you know what i mean like we are
living in in the pax americana man when
historians look back at this time
they're going to be like
man these guys were really angsty and
angry over what they were killing it
like like everybody
should have done parties but that's
exactly why when i told you affirmations
have power
and what i mean to you with you know
media this just validated it
when you say the same thing a million
times if hitler used to say
if you tell a lie enough times you
eventually end up believing it the big
lie that is their
philosophy say it over and over there is
so much positive and negative power
in affirmations so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]